it is time now for CBS Morning steals
where we share items that might help
make your day a little better all at
exclusive discounts to start shopping
right now scan the QR code on your
screen there you see it or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Werner who's also a classmate of mine
from the University of Rhode Island
go right here in the studio to talk to
me about some of these incredible
products good morning good to see you
good morning it's great to see you and
this first item it's all about you all
right whether you have children or you
love the outdoors this is a must so we
start it all folded up it actually fits
into a bag you can carry it hands-free
opens up into what can be a stroller a
wagon and or both so let's should we
show our little model yes so when you
put them in they do have five point
harnesses you're gonna be able to have
two kids look at baby Harlow right now
sitting in there playing with it having
so much fun baby in you can put all your
supplies in you could throw the diaper
bag in there and this is wonderful for
that age but in addition to babies okay
what about when you're going to a
sporting event or going to the beach you
need to bring a lot of gear this is also
designed for that I Garden so I loaded
this up with potting soil and all my
plants this week and there I was in my
garden having fun and using this so it
was easier to pull everything also that
you could put like a little baby like
Harlow on the top of this and below if
you're going to an outdoor concert some
adult beverages
the University of Rhode Island
so this is creative outdoor and right
now it is
293.50 over a hundred dollars savings
three dollars fifty cents 100 bucks you
saved over a hundred all right yes okay
so every Sunday I cook for the entire
week I have four children sometimes
they're home sometimes they're not I
want the food to last well this is the
Debbie Meyer green boxes when you get
your fruit at home like my bestie candy
she had her strawberries in one of these
she said two weeks in and they're still
great wow so you put them in you just
put the lid on and your food is going to
last longer so think about the price of
groceries right now yeah you do not want
to pull it you don't want them to spoil
right so this is going to have it last
longer made in the United States lab
tested so we know that it's great what's
the price how many do you get yes so
you're gonna get a 32 piece set for this
and it is 18 and 18.
amazing fill your fridge fill the
freezer by the way dishwasher and
microwave safe okay love it love it all
right what we got here we have alarms
and our houses and our cars but what
about a personal safety device this is
she's birdie I've got two girls on
college campuses right now the moms who
invented this Ally and Amy they were
setting their girls off to college and
they wanted them to have a personal
alarm I'm going to warn you yeah we're
gonna in a minute it's gonna get a
little loud you pull the top pin out
yes and you hear that sound 130 decibels
in addition it's got a flashing light
you know there was just somebody here in
Central Park but that was just recently
you want to have something where you can
divert the attention and have people
find you and see you if you're having an
emergency trust your gut
19.99 so 33 off love it first one here
here we go uh-oh a little oh a little
carpool karaoke okay
go ahead yes
yes so this is 42.99 28 off unbelievable
you can change your voice it's got sound
effects ready listen to this
of course we partner with all these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything you saw today scan that QR code
on your screen or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now